105 i think we're gonna get underway all
right let me go ahead and get everything
all right you're all set to go all right
well
welcome everybody to the uh orientation
for the environment and agricultural
committee
i am your chairman howard pearl from
loudoun
and now there's some of you i have not
met most of you i know but uh
it's great to see you all here today i
have a little script i have to read to
open the meeting so i will do that and
then we'll get underway and follow the
agenda
as chair of the house and environment
and agricultural committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules and
rsa 91a anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call 271
3600 or email
hcs at leg dot state dot new hampshire
dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer committee researcher will
be the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
barbara i think you immediately i'm also
i'll set now
if everyone could um if everyone could
unmute now so that we can roll through
this quickly
hi yes i'm here and i am
in my dining room my husband is
in around the room here so
thank you representative contour
i am home currently alone
uh representative bixby i am uh
present i am uh currently at home and
alone in my study
representative murray uh yes hi here i
am
home and i have um my children in the
room adjacent to me that i'm alone in my
office
representative kennedy hi i'm here
and i just have my baby in the room with
me
representative stapleton i'm here and
i'm in my office at home in claremont
alone
uh representative davis
i'm here i'm alone in my truck and i'm
on an iphone i hope that's okay
we can hear you fine uh representative
homola if i pronounce your name wrong
represent mason can you unmute yourself
please
yeah um yes president and i'm alone in
my
office at work okay representative
sanborn
representative and i can see your
icon but cannot hear you
we'll come back to you if you have a
chance to unmute yourself
representation i'm here
and i am home alone rev's embolden
i'm here and i'm currently home alone
representative
president and i'm in my home office
alone
representative von plinsky i believe
he's absent
representative kaplan yes i'm here in
henniker
in my home alone okay uh
representative perez unmute yourself
please thank you
i'm here at home alone okay
hello representative sanborn
i believe she's having some technical
difficulties i can see her on the screen
um and mr chair i am here
and i am in my home office alone
okay um if i
all right thank you representative
contour
um mr chair before we move on uh you do
see representative sanborn on the screen
but she has not confirmed um that she is
present in her whereabouts
i just want to say that yeah it does
look like she's
maybe having some technical issues so
perhaps christina can
assist her and see if we can get her uh
there when we do we'll uh
confirm her presence and her um
whereabouts absolutely representative
sanborn
can you just um hang up and call back in
again
and then i'll call you if you can't get
thank you christina well welcome
everyone uh to the environment
agricultural committee this is our our
first meeting together officially and
uh i'm very honored and humbled to have
the opportunity to uh preside over
the best committee in the new hampshire
house that's
my opinion and i think you'll all come
to
uh share that same opinion as we go
throughout the next couple of years
together
uh this is my third term on the house
committee
and uh i just on this particular
committee and i and i like it it's uh
it's really been a great experience for
me uh
the everyone that has been on the
committee with us has done a terrific
job
on either side of the aisle we tend to
check our politics at the door for the
most part and we come in and do our job
and we work together
like every committee should and i'm very
honored to be a part of that
i'm going to uh just keep it brief
because we've got
till about 2 p.m and then we're going to
have a presentation by
former chairs of of the house
of the house environment and ag
committee who work with
the council of state governments and so
i want to see if we can get through most
of our agenda prior to that
uh i'm going to ask the clerk just to
recognize
representative sanbon and representative
homola again it looks like they are both
on
and we could get them representative
sanborn could you state um
if you're present and your location
please
looks like she's still having some
difficulties representative pomola if
and i've
represented if i pronounce your name
wrong could you please correct me
no that is correct thank you um thank
you for waiting sorry my link wasn't
working and i just got this resolved
but um i'm from hollis i'm here in
hollis now and and could you state where
you
are are you alone or and where are you
i am in my home and i
am alone in my dining room thank you
uh let me try representative sam boyne
uh mr chair still having difficulty okay
we'll move along mr chair
uh i just got a text from kevin
representative verville
and he is also having difficulty signing
in
okay so i i'm trying to
get the link to him this is a
representative jamal if i could just
interject the first link that we were
sent actually went to
a labor meeting um
just so you know that's where we i think
maybe we've been hiding in some limbo
there
i'll go ahead and take care of that i'll
contact representative verville for you
i also have a text i have a actually a
post on facebook from representative
vail she's also looking to find the link
to this meeting
well why don't we continue on with our
uh introductions and uh
as the other folks come in we'll uh
we'll hopefully get all of this resolved
before we get into the
the really good stuff so
uh representative aaron is uh my vice
chair and uh i'd
like to give her a couple of minutes to
say hello and introduce herself
yes hello to everybody and i
want to thank you all for
coming today and i
was on this committee for the last term
for the last two year term and i am very
happy to be back
uh i think we've we've got some
good work ahead of us and i look forward
to working with all of you
i am i'm also going to be serving on the
transportation committee
so uh i guess i'll be busy this uh this
uh
biennium thank you
certainly thank you uh representative
comtel when we go to you next
she's serving as the clerk and has done
a terrific job
the last term as clerk and uh she's
certainly going to take uh
bear the brunt of a lot of the work on
our committee and being the clerk and
i just want to personally thank you for
taking on that task because i know with
the uh
doing the su zoom makes it a much bigger
challenge than when we're all
in person so why don't you go ahead and
introduce yourself
thank you um this is my third term in
the house
in my third term on the environmental
agricultural committee
i have been visiting the agricultural
committee
for many years and thoroughly
enjoy agriculture and think it's an
essential part of
our state and keeping um feeding
our our population
and i do have a farm that has been doing
hydroponics since 2004.
we are currently uh expanding into
specialty berries
and uh we've raised animals from time to
time
so um and just to reiterate this is the
best committee in the house
there is no doubt about it we all get
along
and we drop the politics at the door we
are a policy committee and we're all
about making uh legislation better for
the state
so anyways thank you representative
bixby is our ranking member so i think
uh hello everyone glad to see you all
here
and this is going to be my fifth term on
environment agriculture also the fifth
term in the legislature
i wanted to get onto this committee one
in my
when i first started and i have not
regretted that decision
since um and i can
reiterate what a lot of what everyone
else has said this really is the best
committee
um uh we uh
really work in a collegial way and uh
i would you know just like to you know
second what uh people have said about
leaving the politics at the door
we focus on policy that has to do with
environment and agriculture here
and anything else we deal with elsewhere
so i'm looking forward to
getting to the work of the committee and
uh we'll be touching on some of the
bills that we're
likely to be hearing a bit later on i
assume but
um i think this there seems to be a
broad range from solid waste to
agricultural issues to animal rights
animal welfare issues
and i think it'll keep us busy so
welcome everyone thank you
representative
i'm going to throw it next to the deputy
ranking member which is
representative megan murray thank you
it's good to see everybody again
uh this is my second term on environment
and agriculture and i absolutely
love the time that i spent last term
working with you all on various aspects
of
policy i learned a lot as a freshman and
i think that you all
who are freshmen will find that
enlightening as well because we really
do
focus on the policy matters and i'm
excited to serve alongside of you guys
and if you have any questions
um just reach out thanks
thank you representative murray so i'm
going to stop again and have the clerk
uh continue the role it looks like uh
representative sanborn representative
verville
and christina looks like we've got
another one down here that may have used
my link
i'm not sure if we can identify who that
might be
representative sanborn are you able to
verify that
i'm here perfect and where are you
and are you alone i'm at home and i am
alone
representative verville excuse me yeah
can you hear me
i can perfect yeah yeah sorry i i just
got
uh i just got on so i'm not really sure
what
um so i'm asked to
recognize that you're present and where
you are and if you are alone
yeah i'm in my office and there are
people passing by occasionally
okay thank you and
is there anyone else on the zoom call
that i have not
called i just uh got another text from
representative hyland i guess that's
who's
been trying to get in and she says she's
been waiting to be let in for 20 minutes
so
i don't know if that helps at all okay
um christina will you be able to take
care of that
absolutely and and there is one like i
said there's one more person on that i
can see that looks like has used my link
all right i'm gonna continue on i guess
for now that we
uh so that we can kind of try to stay on
schedule and we'll uh circle back for
any other new members that come on
so i did forward you all a uh
an agenda for the this organization
uh well i guess it's actually our
orientation our organization
uh one of the things that is going to be
unique to this year for those members
who were here in the past and
it will be i guess just a normal course
of business for those
folks who are new was the the hybrid
meeting policy
we've uh never done zoom meetings
in the in the past sessions other than
we did in one
exact session i guess this uh the end of
last season so
it is uh it is my desire to have all of
us in the committee room as much as we
possibly can because it really improves
the experience for
all of us as a committee and for
all also for all of the folks that are
testifying now all testimonies will be
done by zoom
the only exception to that may be the
bill sponsor
um if if i'm able in the room
and we have wrong enough to to still
maintain our social distancing i i will
be allowed to
let the person testifying that you know
the sponsor and basically any reps
that are there to speak on the bill so
that is the only exception to that other
than that all of the
uh testimony that you receive will come
in
via zoom so it's going to be a hybrid
meeting program
anyone that is able to attend we will be
maintaining social distancing
you'll be required to wear a mask and
there will be
air handling machines that are i'm told
are going to
clean the room on a very regular basis i
don't know the schedule specifically but
we could find out if anyone's interested
the speaker has the
uh as the details on that so we're
making our best effort to make
everything as safe as possible for in
person but i still do recognize that
there are some of you that that may have
some health concerns and
if that's the case we're going to
provide the ability for you to come in
through zoom
but as you can see we're having some
technical difficulties even today
getting folks on and
and we will i assume on every zoom
meeting we have because that's pretty
much how it works so
i would i would just encourage that
everyone that is possibly able to please
attend in person and we'll talk about
that again in the exact session
is there any questions or concerns on
that before i move on
uh mr chair uh looks like uh
representative highland is
on may right find out where she is thank
you yes please do
uh representative highland would you
stay uh where you
hi yeah oh hi there we go so uh
i am in france's town and i am alone
here in my office
um but i the camera being off makes it
easier for my internet to be more stable
so i can hear everyone so that's why i
keep the camera off but i'm here alone
okay great thank you very much
howard it's catherine can i just ask you
a question
i'm sorry i my doorbell was ringing so i
didn't hear did you
say anything about masks
yes so the uh excuse me if you were
attending in person
we will uh we'll have appropriate social
distancing
masks will be required and there will
there are
air handling machines that will be
cleaning the air in the room several
times an hour thank you
you're welcome any other questions
all right at any point in time if
anybody has one
raise your hand i'm trying to get used
to this too and so well or just
interrupt me either way
whatever works for you uh all right next
on the agenda is the start times and
notice of absence
so with the amount of bills that we have
and we're trying to do them all
uh through using this hybrid method
we're going to be assigned uh the room
to use for the day
we basically they're going to have two
or three rooms that they can set up and
do this with so
the committees are going to be sharing
the rooms we
we traditionally had met on a tuesday or
a wednesday
i i'm unsure right now as to what day
we're going to be assigned to meet
it's going to be a sign by the speaker
and that's the day i'm going to have to
work with so
i will let you know as soon as i do he's
trying to get all of this figured out as
they're still assigning bills
to the committees and once he has a
handle on what the workload is going to
be and what our time frame will be
needed to do that work then they will uh
assign us a day and we will start from
there
he has also indicated that he'd like us
to work a full day when we do it so that
we can get as much in as possible
so uh he wants us to start at 9 a.m and
go as long as we need to or as close to
5 as we can so
there will be some some longer days but
we'll certainly provide appropriate
breaks and
lunch breaks and things like that to
make sure that we're
taking care of you keeping you in good
shape
uh next on our agenda is email
communication for legislative business
so uh excuse me i would suggest uh
that you you should have all received a
notification from the clerk
requesting what email you'd like for
official communication
i would suggest that you use one email
for all of your your
work and make sure that we have that
email in committee as well so that
we're getting the communications to you
properly i know i've
had a couple of folks that i've had to
go in so far and fix it but just please
make sure that we have on file and email
to get to you so that
we can communicate appropriately
dress in decorum so normally when we're
in the house
you know when we're in committee we're
required to dress uh in
in business attire and i would suggest
that the same occurs if you're going to
come in by zoom because
this is still a public meeting the
public is still going to see you
and it's important that we uh send a
you know a good message to them that
we're we're here
we're dressed to be professional and for
success and that we
you know have the respect for them that
we want to
be showing ourselves and uh so i think
it's real important that we still
maintain decorum even though it's
kind of nice sometimes when you're at
home to hang around in a sweatshirt and
sweatpants maybe but i i don't i don't
feel that that's the best look for us as
a committee when we're uh
on an official uh meeting in uh
receiving testimony so
i would ask that you uh maintain decorum
just as if you were in person
any questions on that from anyone
anything i've covered so far
howard i i do have a question sure
um just about my name badge broke
so i obviously am a returning rep who do
i contact
oh judy judy has her hand up i think she
knows the answer go ahead judy
[Laughter]
you got on mute so i um
i also needed some new name badges and i
just
um contacted the house clerk
or you can contact um
the speaker's office and they will
direct you
to the people who will send you
um the paperwork actually you know what
i have the email with the paperwork and
i'll just forward it to you
and you can just fill it out and tell
them what you want
send it in with a check and you're done
thank you very much i appreciate it
excellent all right if anybody else has
a concern with name badges
i would say reach out to representative
aaron and she will get the
appropriate info to you all right food
coffee and lunch breaks uh
so during the time when we are
in uh our committee and doing our
committee work and receiving testimony
we we should not be eating either at our
desk
or on camera we want to make sure again
that we're
we're showing the people that we're
interested in paying attention to what
they're saying
um you can have a drink you know
typically water or
sometimes i'll have an iced tea
something like that uh but
keep it down to uh you know to that and
let's just try to
again maintain that respect that we that
we have for the folks that have come to
testify
use of electronic devices you know
we're living in an electronic age and
we're all have a lot of distractions but
again
the biggest thing is we want to make
sure that the people that are testifying
feel like we're paying attention to them
so sometimes it's necessary when someone
is testifying to you know they might
cite something that you want to look up
a specific rsa or something that you
find of interest and
so i would encourage you to again just
be respectful pay attention to the folks
that are testifying if you have
something that you need to do
that you want to look up then by all
means do it but but
sort of keep it related to what's going
on in the room and what's going on
relative to the bill we're hearing
committee room drawers so when and if we
ever do get back into the state house
full time there are committee drawers
that are that are in our committee room
that you can keep your paperwork in
currently uh that has been suspended
because of the pandemic so if you're
coming to the state house to be in
person you'll need to bring everything
with you and
take it all back with you and it's kind
of a pain but
when we are in the committee room there
are emergency procedures for
exiting and there's signs posted on the
wall uh
they're showing the places we should go
you know the correct routes to get out
and where we should meet so
i think when we finally get back in
there we'll perhaps cover this a little
more
in detail because kind of on zoom it
doesn't doesn't seem as relative if
we're not in the room
so uh representative bolden has agreed
to be
our security notification expert
so when we are in the committee room he
will be seated closest to the door
and if in the event there is some reason
that we have a
you know an issue and we need to alert
security
he is uh he knows the protocols and
procedures and i'll either
you know tell him to do so or if he
feels there's a reason he he will do so
but we'll get that communicated
he will uh he will be the person that
will take care of that
again fire alarm and exits uh those are
all
signed appropriately if you are there in
the uh in the
lob i guess if you're at home you're
sort of on your own for your fire alarms
and exits but i'll trust that you all
all right that's the end of our first uh
section any
questions that anybody has there or
comments that you'd like to make
mr chair yes um the only thing i would
like to say
is i just like to reiterate something
about
um electronic devices um
it's very um important
that the public doesn't see you
scrolling on your phones i think it's um
they appreciate our committee because we
really do pay attention
so if you i would think keep your cell
phones off
the table um i think isn't is important
that's all i want to say yeah that's
typically the rule when we're in in
committee and thank you for uh
for adding to that you know we we
generally keep them under the table
down out of sight if possible and i
guess i would say the same to you if
you're
at home in in doing this via zoom just
again it's it's about the respect for
the folks that are testifying
you know they're they have taken their
time to come in and
in many of these bills it's a very
passionate thing and some of them are
pretty nervous and
scared to to be there you know they're
not used to speaking in front of people
and
so we just want to make sure we're
giving them our respect and our
attention
all right i'm going to go on to the
committee
so our charge is the environment and ag
committee is covered under rule 31f
and if you look through the material
that you were
provided in the in the email that i sent
you
there should be uh all of this should be
listed in there and if i've missed
something
my apologies and we'll certainly get it
to you if you can't find it
any questions on on rule 31 of us
yep representative aaron so
for uh the newer legislators on our
committee here uh 31f
rep refers to the house rules
and so much of how we operate
uh has its uh
definitions in our house rules so
if you haven't read them please make
sure you do
they are posted on the gen court website
for
the portion of the website that deals
with the house of representatives
so i just wanted to point that out to
some of the newer people
thank you i personally am so interested
i downloaded the entire set and have
them here for me to
peruse in the evening when i'm bored
[Laughter]
uh all right partisan balance
i i think this is important to cover
because as i said
we typically check our uh our parties at
the door when we come in and work but
there is a
a formula for how our committee is and
and how every committee is set up
so we have uh 19 members on our
committee 10 of which are
republican and nine are democrat and and
that is basically the balance of
how it divvies out because of the the
balance in the house of representatives
so when we were first elected we were
what 218 to 182
i think was the original since the
passing of speaker hinch
we uh we were down to 217 on our side
on the republican side but but that is
the makeup of the
committee it's that same partisan
balance as close as it can be to
what is uh the makeup of the house
but again i i can't stress this enough
and
we we this committee has always worked
extremely well
together there are certainly issues and
there may be one or two
or a per session maybe that's typically
about it we will see a party-line vote
but you will find the vast majority of
our bills will come up
come out of our committee uh with us all
in unison and supporting it because we
do the work
and we all listen to each other and we
have that dialogue and we find a way to
get it so that everybody can be on board
and so i think that's real important
um representative dixie if at any point
in time there's something that you'd
like to add into this by all means just
jump in all right
i certainly i'd just like to amplify
that um
that the the nonpartisan aspect of it
and
um one of the things one one way that i
i think that um bob hefner who was
actually on this call
uh phrased it this way uh when he was
the chair
uh when we you know when we walk into
the ena room
uh we uh leave our div
we leave divisive issues that the party
that are
sort of party line at the door uh so
we don't mention sort of the hot button
issues that
have clear partisan divides because we
want to make sure we're focusing on
the business of our committee and
working on it in a non-partisan way
thank you well said and uh we will be
receiving a uh
a presentation from former chairs hafner
and sad they're both on and i
i welcome them on i can see you're here
and i look forward to your presentation
okay uh committee seating you will see
that i included a committee seating
chart
we have always uh done mixed seating
where
you know when we try to put every other
person uh
by party affiliation so that we can all
get a chance to talk with each other and
have good interactive dialogue
so i have come up with a seating plan
and uh
you know if if there's someone has a
concern i would say
please reach out to me and we'll do our
okay typical bill topics
so there is a section that we included
here and i have to scroll down and find
that myself
often uh these are the the build topics
that are regularly within our committee
there certainly are some deviations at
time but uh
current use issues solid waste issues
including recycling landfills
product of stewardship agricultural
support and promotion
is the federal food safety modernization
act we'll certainly have one this year
on that because we need to extend it
that's actually a bill that i had put in
issues dealing with farm stands issues
dealing with pesticides those are
certainly a regular
regular topic that we discuss within the
committee
and animal welfare both farm and
household
i would say the last three or four years
that has dominated the majority of the
of our time
um in in the bills that have come before
our committee has certainly spent
on animal welfare bills i know we have
less this year it looks to me like not
all bills have been assigned yet but
looking through the lsrs
we definitely have less to do with that
and i think
those of us who've been here in the past
will take a welcome deep breath on that
one
certainly has consumed a good amount of
okay early bill's going to second
committee
so there are sometimes there are bills
that go to more than one committee
and uh i haven't looked through i'm sure
there are well i know there's some of
ours that will because anything that has
a fiscal note
often goes over to finance or ways and
means depending on
what the bill is whether it's an income
or an expense so those bills will get a
priority and they will be heard first
so that they can get through the process
quicker and get to that second committee
if you've uh in your orientation when
you first became a rep i'm sure they
talked about crossover
and all of the deadlines that the house
has and so we have to make sure we get
all these bills through all of the
committees prior to those deadlines that
the house
set and some of this um for those of you
who are freshmen it may
seem overwhelming at times there's uh
there's there's a lot of things to
remember
you don't have to remember them all
we'll we'll all be there for you and by
all means
reach out and ask questions to myself to
any member of the committee
regardless of party we're all here to
work together and we're all here to help
you and uh
you know we want to make sure that it's
a good experience as well as a learning
experience
myself included this uh this being my
first term as a chair there's a lot i'm
learning
and i certainly will be leaning on
representative bixby as he's had
past experience in leadership and we'll
work through this together and we'll
we'll get it done
any questions on anything that i've
all right i don't see any hands and i
don't hear anybody yelling so i'll
continue on
we'll go to sub committees so there are
there are five subcommittees within our
committee so sometimes we have bills
that need more work than
what the full committee can can do
because it's just too time consuming
and so we'll break out into smaller
groups at times which are called
subcommittees
and those uh subcommittees will do the
legwork so to speak if we have a bill
that
we we just need more information on and
there are
five different subcommittees and i
included this in in your
email handout there's environmental
policy
agricultural policy current use
animal protection and licensing and
solid waste
so those are the five subcommittees what
i'd like you all to do is
take a look at those subcommittees and
i'd like you to pick
two that you think you would have an
interest in and send
myself or judy or both of us an email
and let us know
that you're that's a committee a
subcommittee you'd like to be placed
upon
now inevitably i've only got room for
about six people on each committee so
there may be some folks that
you know you you'll pick too many on one
committee and not enough on another but
if you'll tell me the committees you're
interested in i will try and get you
the subcommittees i mean i will try and
get you on those committees
and if i may have to assign you to
something a little different than what
you asked for but i'll do my best to
to get you where you want to be so if
you could do that
in the next few days would be very
yeah so i just want to
say that not always do these
commit subcommittees meet they only meet
when
we have a bill that uh needs some work
on it
so just because you are on uh you know
current use
subcommittee doesn't necessarily mean
that
you know you're going to have any
additional huge workload
that's a great point and uh again not
all the bills have been assigned to our
committee
i looked this morning and i believe we
were up to 18.
i anticipate we'll probably have
somewhere between 22 and 25 if
things go but we'll have to wait and see
once the final disposition to the
committees is done
yeah any any further committees oh go
ahead
um so i actually took a look um and i i
can send this out to everyone
after this meeting but i made a
spreadsheet of
the bills that are definitely coming to
our committee and prior to that i had
gone through the lsrs
and about half a dozen of the ones that
i thought might be coming to us are
actually going somewhere else
and there are no bills that have been no
lsrs that have been turned into bills
that have not been assigned yet and
there are only two
left that have not been turned into
bills that are likely to come to us
so i can send that out and uh of course
there might be a few that i
missed on my pass through the lsrs or um
someone might have a different idea
about what should come to my
our committee than i do but
but i i think we're probably going to be
close to about 20.
yeah okay excellent representative aaron
yeah um so i actually haven't had a
chance to really look
through the list so representative bixby
are have you seen how many in that list
maybe have already been through this
committee last term
and are returning because they were not
uh
passed in one way shape or form um
about half of them are ones that are are
repeats uh
and i um i i can
i can flag that on the document that i
send out
i hadn't put it onto the document yet
but um
and certainly your bill for des is one
of them
uh which and it was it was already good
when we got it last year and it was
perfect when we sent it out so i i'm
anticipating that some of those are
going to be
uh pretty straightforward and efficient
to work through again
uh there might be some others that are
require a little bit more
um work given changes in circumstances
and whatnot
yeah i would uh add on to that that
there
for some of us you're going to see a lot
of recycled language
as we talked about it and i think those
bills will go through fairly quickly and
and the committee's done a lot of work
on them already so i think we'll uh i
think we'll do well with it
i'm hopeful that we're going to have
shorter
shorter hearing days than what we had in
the last year because
any other questions on subcommittees and
all right so uh
there's you'll see in the handout that i
provided there's a lot of
information about how subcommittees work
they're they're very similar
to the way the regular committee works
as far as notification and
things of that nature and uh i don't
think i'm going to go over all of that i
think you all can
and can read it and you'll sort of get a
real handle for it after we have our
first
committee hearing that you'll see a lot
of the will be
so calendar notice uh so that
i will provide as much notice as i
possibly can for
for any of the things that are going on
in our committee but there are times
sometimes where you know something might
slip by me you know it's in the calendar
and i may not
you may not get noticed personally from
me on our on our committee email so
i would always recommend that you keep
an eye on the calendar every week when
it comes out
it's a really good idea and and as with
any of this information i'm giving you
today if you
have any questions going on please reach
out to myself or judy or
or peter or you know and we'll
collectively we'll find the answer if we
okay bill files i think i covered this
earlier with the committee rooms and
drawers
uh again that i'll reiterate you'll need
to
bring everything with you when you come
to uh the hearings and exec
sessions that you'll need because uh at
this point we can't store
anything in the uh legislative office
building
so i'll break from my agenda just for a
moment here
i was gonna call it the lob there are
many acronyms within
the state government that we use
ols the office of legislative services
lob the legislative office building
we tend to seize acronyms sometimes and
for those of you that are new
you're going to look at us and go what
the heck are you talking about and i
totally get that so
don't hesitate to ask we just sort of
use these shortcuts to get through
things and you'll pick them up
really quickly as you go along but by
all means if
if i say something that like that you
know using an acronym
and you don't know what it means feel
free to just interrupt me and ask me for
clarifications because i want to make
okay duties of committee members
so uh the duties of the chair can be
found in house rule 100.
judy talked earlier about where to find
the house rules and if you have trouble
finding them
by all means ask the vice chair
works in conjunction with the chair and
presides over the hearings in the
meetings when the chair is absent or
unable to preside
so there'll be some bills that i have
sponsored myself that are coming to our
committee
in in that case judy will step in and
take the chair role
during that hearing uh any bill that
you have sponsored or co-sponsored if
you speak on it you are not allowed to
interview the
the any of the further testimonials that
come in from
from other folks if you didn't speak on
it i cleared this
with the uh ran this scenario by the
speaker because
uh it's been different two different
times that i've been there but the
speaker's position is
if you are a co-sponsor or a sponsor and
you did not speak then you rema
you may remain in your your seat and you
may interview
the other people witnesses who are
testifying
or i guess witness isn't the right word
any of the other folks that have come in
to testify
so that that is a little change from
last year and again
some of these nuances occur depending
upon the speaker's position
so it will be our position this year
that
if you have spoken and testified on a
bill
you may not interview and ask questions
of any other folks that are testifying
but if you have not testified then you
will be able to
is that clear does everybody understand
where i'm going with that
all right uh representative aaron yeah
so yes i'm clear on that
so but what that means is if you are the
sponsor
and you present the bill then you cannot
ask
questions of any of the um
uh you know people who are testifying on
it
because you've already presented the
bill and spoken on it
is that correct okay that is correct now
if for those of you who are new if you
are
the prime sponsor on a bill and you're
not able to do it you can ask one of
your co-sponsors to introduce the bill
so just uh those are some of the little
nuances that occur
any further questions on that area
before i move on
yeah i had a like a pragmatic question
on that
um okay yep if you were meeting in
person
generally um the member would like sit
where the the public sits to just to
sort of
show some physical distance in the past
what how do we
separate that and make folks aware who
might be participating by zoom if you
are
telephonically meeting and sitting this
one out so to speak
i'm going to actually have to get a
little further guidance on that before i
answer because
i don't know the answer to that it's
going to be a little bit challenging to
do that
and that's part of the reason that i
really like in-person meeting if
possible but
let me i'm going to make note of that
question and i'm going to i'm going to
get an answer before i
just stumble my way through it is that
could you repeat that question i didn't
quite hear it sounded like she was
asking how do you ask questions of
people who are testifying if you're
remote is that
was that the question no that wasn't the
question
so generally when we would be when we've
met in person
and you are a sponsor or a co-sponsor
and are speaking on your bill you would
physically remove yourself from the
committee chair location
and sit where the public members sit
um during that time so i'm just wanting
to make sure that's clear to the folks
participating
uh remotely that you're sort of
not participating in the same manner
right no it i'm not sure how we would
distinguish that on zoom because i think
it would be too much of a challenge to
take you out of being a panelist and put
you back in
you know i think that would be a
challenge so let me see i'll ask that
question and let me see if i can get a
little further clarification
mr chair yes maybe
if you are the sponsor and you are
speaking to the bill then maybe you just
remain
mute um for the entire
that hearing keep your mute button on
might be the way to go that would
probably be a
a wise idea that way you wouldn't slip
up and ask a question
and i'll try to keep on top of it as
well as as far as who's testified and
who's asking any other questions before
we
move forward
all right we've got about seven more
minutes before our
presentation and i think if i probably
move along quickly we can get through
as we go okay so duties of committee
members
now again your duties uh let's see
that's the chair
i gotta oh sorry i got myself in the
is there any further questions on uh the
duties of the committee members
i i may just skip through this if you're
okay i'm going to move on so our
committee researcher is
christina dyer christina is on the call
today and she's worked with some of you
trying to
get through you know deal with your
technology issues
our our former committee uh researcher
was with joel
anderson and i just will give a shout
out to joel because
those of us who've been there we'll
really miss him
uh he has was a walking textbook of
information
and a uh a tremendous
depth of knowledge within the within our
committee and
i will say to christina i welcome
for to our committee as researcher and
uh you you've got big shoes to fill
yeah joel did a great job
i am sure you do but we welcome you
aboard look forward to working with you
so christina's contact information is
here in the information that i handed
out
her phone number and and her uh email
address
okay our house committee assistant is uh
heather goalie
heather's been there for quite a few
years as well and has done a tremendous
job working with our committee
her contact info and job description is
also included in the information that i
handed out to you
and it with any of these folks if you
have concerns they're here to help us
and they really do a great job in
working with us
so by all means reach out to them as
okay any questions on that before i move
to the next section
all right i don't see any so public
hearings
the i discussed the hybrid meetings
howard i just
wanted to make a brief comment in terms
of the um
the researcher the the committee
researcher essentially
does um gathers information
that the committee knows that it's going
to be needing uh
for uh bills that we're working on
and uh it is
it's essentially the the um the purview
of the chair or the vice chair to do the
contacts
with the committee researcher um
and uh if members want to have research
done on a particular issue or with a
particular set of questions
they should channel it through you
great point peter thank you
i appreciate you filling in that info
because i did forget that
all right public hearing uh hybrid
meetings in the quorum we talked about
the hybrid meeting part of it
that again i want you all to
feel comfortable and safe and we we're
going to do our best to
have that environment for for in person
and
and i will uh make my statement one more
time
and then i'll leave it be it's
it's an experience um and we do such a
good job together and being there and
discussing and
and you know and taking in the
information especially on the executive
sessions
that this committee has always worked
wonderfully together
and uh i feel some of that's not going
to be the same with us on zoom so if
you're able to come please do
and if you have health concerns then i
accept that and i understand it and
we'll do our best to
try and keep you in the loop and feeling
in the
in the virtual room like the regular
room as much as we can
so just the biggest thing is
communication
if there's a question or concern about
anything just please reach out and ask
and and talk to me talk to peter talk to
judy or
you know any of us and let's make sure
we all stay in communication
right from right out of the gate and we
can uh there's nothing we can't solve if
i talked about decorum uh i'll
cover a couple of things under here it's
really of key importance to treat
everyone as you would like to be treated
uh so when we're in the uh
my apologies when we're in the mode of
having a hearing it is real important
that you
direct all of your questions to me as
the chair and
that you uh you ask questions
through the chair to the person
testifying you always ask permission to
ask a question
you know put put your hand up it's going
to be a little harder virtually
but i'll have help annie kennedy is
going to be our
technology person and she'll be watching
that
and alerting me if there are questions
and hands raised
as we get into the hearing process and
but you we always start every question
off with
with uh mr chair may i ask a question
and
i'll always give you permission to do so
as long as there's some reason that i
can't and
and then you'll address the person you
know thank you for coming
uh i appreciate you taking my question
and and then ask your question
but you need to remember that we're
we're not arguing with the with the
people that are coming in to testify
we're getting information from them you
know making speeches
you you're going to absolutely adamantly
disagree with some of the people that
are going to come in and present
information to you you're going to
just completely disagree with everything
they're saying
but you still smile and you keep it
professional and you you ask a question
of some anything you'd like a further
point on but
and if you have a second question a
follow-up you always ask the chair for
permission to ask a follow-up
okay i just
just want to sort of stress that um
that level of respect that we give to
the people who are testifying
uh it is are really critical
that um we maintain
uh respect for everyone who comes in to
testify
whether they're we agree that we agree
with him or not
and uh we do not
cross-examine we uh
we can ask questions we can ask
follow-ups for clarification
but if you think that someone who's
testifying is just simply wrong
that's something that you can bring up
later when we're discussing things as a
committee don't
don't attack never never never
attack a witness absolutely
thank you peter bob and tara we it is
two o'clock
i've probably got five to seven more
minutes would it be okay with you if i
finished through this part before we
went on to your presentation
it's fine with me okay
yeah me too all right thank you i
appreciate that
i know i had your schedule in for two
o'clock
okay so you'll see there's a few more
ground rules that i
included um in
you know the way that you you we handle
our hearings i'll let you review those i
don't think this
i think we've hit the high points on
them
um we've talked about committee members
being sponsors and co-sponsors let's
skip over to executive session
so this is the time where a quorum comes
into play that uh
and that we have to know we're gonna go
through basically a process similar to
what we did at the start of this meeting
to identify who you are if you're
signing on virtually i'm gonna ask at
those times i at least need to see a
picture of you in the beginning you have
your camera on so that i can confirm
it's you
that and you're the one that is voting
because
when we're doing votes it's real
important that we know it's only
committee members and
and that's doing the voting and not
someone else for you
so i i would like to have that visual
confirmation if possible
i realized sometimes there are areas in
the state that you may be
calling from that the technology just
won't support it we'll have to work
around that
if uh if you find yourself in that
situation
any questions on that part of it okay as
we go through executive sessions there's
certain motions that can be made most of
the time this is going to be sorted out
between the ranking member and myself as
far as who's going to be making the
motions
and with that comes the responsibility
of
you'll be called upon for so if we've
got a bill coming forward i
i may when i open up the exact session
and i'll go okay i'm looking for a
motion and i believe rep
i recognize representative bixby to make
a motion and
he'll make his motion and whatever it is
and he'll
then i'll recognize him to speak to it
when uh we'll have a second
and from there
it will then open up to the rest of the
committee to come up with any
points pros or cons again that same
level of respect
goes to the committee members as it does
to the people testifying
you you may completely disagree with the
position that i have and i'm okay with
that
you know if we get into one of those
bills where there's
some you know conflicting opinions but
we we typically
speak to and address each other as you
know representative contour
representative bixby representative
kennedy
whatever it is whomever you're speaking
to those are the people
that's just the respect that we give
each other and it because the public can
view
these executive sessions they cannot
participate
but it's important to demonstrate to
them that we have the respect
between each other as much as we do for
them and we see
enough disrespectful behavior
all around the country and we don't need
that here in new hampshire and
especially not within our committee
and i want to make sure that we treat
each other appropriately and
respectfully so
that's kind of a big big point that i
so there there are motions that can be
made and those again that information is
all listed
within the uh the handouts that i gave
you
uh if i think you'll
you'll find as we go through these
executive sessions that they'll flow
pretty smoothly
it it'll be intriguing the first time
that you go through it as a freshman you
know
you'll you'll watch and see how it rolls
but
there's a there's an order that the role
will be called and but you you'll
you'll have caucuses on on both sides on
the democrat on the republican side
we'll have caucuses
you'll typically understand where we all
are when we
uh when we meet
right so when it comes to voting the
uh i'll call once we're ready i'll ask
if you're ready to vote if there's no
further discussion and then i will
send it to the clerk just as i did at
the beginning of this meeting to
call the role and you'll be asked to
give your vote either
yay or nay yes or no and we'll go from
there
there's information on conflicts of
interest
that you will want to review because
sometimes there are bills
where your outside affiliations um from
your daily life you know we're all
citizens legislators
we all have jobs or lives outside of
this occasionally there are bills that
come in that
you'll have a conflict of interest and
if you have filed one with the clerk
then
you will not be required to vote
otherwise if you are in the room you
peter did i miss anything there
i think that i think that covers it
pretty well um
and we haven't i i don't think we
haven't gotten to the committee reports
yet so
um right right i'll skip down to that
actually because it's kind of oh do we
have a question
sorry i have a question mr chair um on
the voting uh i understand
uh there's still the rule no abstention
you either regret yay or nay unless
you were in the pulled out yeah if you
were in the room
and you do have not filed a conflict
then you must vote
that is correct i'll skip down to
committee reports because it's kind of
relevant to this part of it
so as i talked about making the motions
typically whoever makes the motion will
write the committee report
and that is what shows up in the
calendar and
there's some specific information that
needs to be in the committee report and
that is outlined pretty well in the
handout
and as we get into that we'll we'll kind
of
help you with that because it it can
seem a little daunting at times the
first couple of times you do it
but if you know you're going to make the
motion
this is a suggestion write the committee
report beforehand
and bring it with you and that way once
you've made the motion you've already
got the work done
that committee report is all done you
might have to edit it a little bit
perhaps
you know if we've had some type of
conversation that occurred in the
executive committee that maybe
perhaps changes it a little but if you
can do that beforehand it will be a lot
easier on you and it will be a lot
easier on me
and uh you can you can hand that in and
we can edit it
right then and there and it's done so
just a suggestion something that i've
tried to do
because i do better sitting and writing
them sometimes on my computer
and have it all printed out and bring it
with me and i can edit it a little bit
if i need to
i it's much easier to read too
considering my handwriting isn't always
the best
right so just a another um
aspect of that is that every committee
report has to be
reviewed by the chair and signed signed
off on by the chair
uh so um so you will um
if it if the chair decides if the chair
sees something that is problematic with
your report
yes um the other thing is that if it's
your first time
or first couple of times uh going
through writing a report
uh feel free to lean on any of the um
more more senior members because
everyone has
done this before and um you know has
some experience with it and
uh can give give you good advice
and i will tell you there is really fun
the first calendar you see that has your
name
and as as the committee report it's it's
a really fun experience so
don't shy away from it it's uh it's
really uh
it's it's all part of what you do and
it's just a really cool part of being in
the new hampshire house
okay did i skip over anything uh we
talked about rolls to
roll calls i consent calendar i should
talk about that one um
so as i've said our committee works
really well together
many of our bills come out unanimous
you'll you'll see a lot of 19 to zero
votes come out of our committee
and when that happens as long as it
doesn't have a fiscal note
or an appropriation then it can go on
what's called the consent count
and the important part of that is all
the bills that go on the consent
calendar when we get to the house floor
that that whole consent calendar is
going to be passed with one vote so this
might be sometimes 70 or 80 bills in the
consent calendar
and uh there's no debate on those bills
if they're on the consent calendar and
if they get passed through that way it's
really quick and easy
now you we can put it on as on the
consent calendar as a committee and i
will ask you does anybody have an
objection to this being placed on
consent
and as long as no one does we'll put it
on
someone another member of the house or a
member of you if you change your mind
afterwards
can pull that bill off in the consent
calendar before it goes to the house
floor
literally right up until the time of
when the session starts
and the uh the clerk will make that
announcement are there any bills that
need to be pulled off consent
and then if not then we'll roll through
and vote the consent calendar through so
with us doing our work behind the scenes
and in doing good job as committee and
getting those bills under consent it
really makes our floor time much less
and it makes it
go very smoothly judy peter
all right i guess we got it we talked
about committee reports
uh committee amendments sometimes the
bills that
we have come in need amendments in fact
i'd say almost
always there's something the committee
will find could be a typo it could be
something we pick up during testimony
there's just some things that need to be
changed
so uh as that occurs and the committee
decides how they want to go
then usually a member will volunteer and
pick up and take that committee over to
ols and have an amendment drafted and
that amendment that member will bring
that amendment into
the executive session and present it and
and then the committee will take up that
amendment and vote on it and
if it passes then that will become part
of the bill and it will go through that
way
and so that's when you're writing the
committee report
you want to remember that if an
amendment has been added then
it's important to note that in the
committee report that as amendment
as amended this bill will do such and
such
uh the committee's final vote appears on
the majority
report so if we do have a bill that we
don't all agree on and it doesn't go on
consent calendar
and uh let's say we have one that goes
down party lines so we have ten
republicans that vote yay and
nine democrats that vote nay the report
will
majority report will be from in in that
case would be from the republicans that
voted yes all those that are accepting
and they they would give their reasons
why they supported it
and anyone that was in the minority that
wants to
could write a minority report saying why
you don't support it but the committee
vote of
last thing i have here is field trips
and again we we often as a committee
want new field trips of farms or
ag related businesses or perhaps uh yeah
you know waste treatment plants or
things of that nature whatever it is
that falls under our purview
right now obviously with the pandemic
all of our our tours are kind of placed
on hold
but my hope is as we get through into
summer and
that the pandemic starts to get under
better control that perhaps
the the second half of our session we
can start doing those uh
again because it's a really fun
experience that we as a committee get to
go
do and uh again it kind of helps us all
the
just the camaraderie within our
committee and it's it's an awful lot of
fun you get to go
see some really neat and interesting
things
well with that i'm going to wrap up my
area of it because that's all i have to
say and
yep go ahead peter just won't throw in
one more thing that sort of fits in the
field trip category maybe
um usually uh near the beginning of the
session
we invite um the people from
the departments that we deal with in to
give us a little overview of
of what they do so we'll be inviting in
people from the department of
agriculture markets and foods
from department of health and human
services food protection
and from des solid waste
division uh to give us some overview of
how their departments operate and how we
work with them and
we might also be able to get in some
uh people from unh to talk about
uh their that end of agriculture
in the state of new hampshire yes thank
you peter i forgot to
include that that's a great point and
we'll be
making sure to set that up soon
obviously we won't be having any uh bill
hearings next week
but i would fully anticipate that
possibly the week after
we may again i'm waiting for some
guidance from the speaker's office on
what day we can do that so
i'll keep you uh keep you tuned in tune
as we come to that
anything else any uh questions judy go
ahead yeah yeah
so um one thing that we didn't touch on
at all
is how we are going to be receiving
testimony for these hearings
normally when we meet in our committee
room
and people came for the public hearings
they would bring
documents with them and distribute them
to all the members
to read we would also get emails from
people
telling us uh their position on any
particular piece of legislation
and i suspect this time um you know
since we won't have people coming
in person that whatever documents they
want to share with us
i am sure they are going to send us via
email
i think that the house is
looking into having some sort of web
page for every committee
which will have links on it to display
everybody's different piece of testimony
but that hasn't happened yet
and i just wanted to say that
keep an eye on your email and with
regard to specific pieces of legislation
thank you judy any other questions
mr chair um on the same note um
as what representative aaron was talking
about we usually have a sign-in sheet
um those signing in that are for or
against the bill
um how is that going to work
christina do you want to touch on that
do you have any
further detailed info i'm sorry what was
the question
talking about the blue sheets and the
pink cards as to how that whole process
is going to work when they're virtual
we do not at this moment um i know that
leadership is working on that
um and i anticipate you'll have an
answer this week but at the moment we
don't have
we don't have any updates okay well
we'll keep you posted on that as it gets
worked out and
as that detail becomes available
all right i appreciate you sitting and
listening to me bloviate for an hour and
15 minutes because i know it's been a
long time
i'm going to now introduce the two
former chairs of
our committee representative bob hafner
and representative
tara sad they are with the council of
state governments and
i am going to turn it over to them for
roughly uh
half hour is that right bob yes all
right
take it away okay thank you howard and
and you know i think you've done a great
job with this
and peter and barbara it's good to see
uh i i i will start
i think karen and i need to introduce
ourselves
uh i am bob heffner i
am a former chair a former republican
uh well still a republican but i i was a
republican chair
uh tara and i served the same 10 years
in the legislature
and we changed majorities
every term that we were there
so when the majority changed tara and i
would just get up and change
chairs and everything else we proceed
like at all
uh but we we left the legislature
well this will be a third term out and
uh we want to work for the council of
state governments
uh as consultants
uh we we are the agriculture and rural
policy advisors uh so with that i'm
gonna
let tara introduce herself hello
everyone
and welcome to the best committee in the
house environment and agriculture
i'm i must say i miss it and um welcome
back to everybody
who was here before and welcome to the
new people
just coming in if you don't know already
it's going to be just a wonderful part
of your life
that you're going to be going into it's
great um
as i said the environment and
agriculture committee is the best
in the entire house um we always got
along so well together and from
what i can see from your chair the um
wonderful introduction that he gave to
everybody about what is expected
you're going to have fun and it's going
to be well run so congratulations
um i'm tara sad
like bob said we were in for 10 years
i was chair or ranking member for the
majority of that time
um i live in walpole which is a small
town right on the connecticut river
and peter i see that you know what i'm
going to be saying um
walpole has more dairy farms than any
other town in the state of new hampshire
so that's why i chose agriculture
committee
not that i'm a farmer because i'm not
i've never milked a cow
but i was fighting for my constituents
and that's what i enjoyed doing so much
solving problems
for the agricultural and environmental
parts of our state it's very important
you have a big job ahead of you
and i know that you're going to do a
great job
i feel sorry for you that you're not
sitting in room 303 right now
and looking at everybody face to face
because that's
the fun part getting to know everybody
and
talk about the grandkids and talk about
you know what's going on at home
that's what binds the committee together
so hopefully by the time the term is
over you're going to be able to
meet comfortably together and go on
those wonderful field trips which are
always my favorite things to do
as bob said um we both are
agriculture and rural affairs policy
consultants for
council of state governments so bob do
you want to start
off with explaining just exactly what
csg is and what we do
and and uh just ahead to the two of us
being
the consultants for agriculture and
rural
uh uh we we job share that
uh we decided to do that the day i lost
my last election
and we've been doing it ever since uh
csg is a national
organization that meets primarily
regionally uh there there is a
national organization that's
headquartered in lexington
kentucky uh
but we have four regions there's at
we are in the eastern region
that includes 11 states
from maryland and delaware up through
new jersey pennsylvania and new york and
all six new england states
we also have five eastern canadian
provinces
uh from ontario over to
uh not only quebec but the uh
maritimes other than the
newfoundland they they have chosen not
to be
part of any organization legislatively
um we also have
it's certainly not northeast but we have
puerto rico and the us virgin islands as
part of our organization
uh and i think that's simply because no
one else asked them to join and we did
and they came and have been a member
ever since
um one of the things
i i really like about csg
is we are regional uh you know the
problems
in maryland or pennsylvania
for agriculture are pretty much the
exact same problems we have in new
hampshire
or maine it really
it it's not much different between our
state's
delaware may be a little different with
all those chickens down there
and pretty flat land but uh it's
certainly a whole lot different
than agriculture in montana or iowa
um so it's just kind of nice to all
uh meet regionally with folks that have
the same problems
i'll just give a little bit of the
history of how
csg came about uh
there was a legislator in the northeast
said hey you know we
are having problems in one state we
don't know what anybody else is doing
we think it would be a great forum if we
could get folks together
uh from different states and it started
out in the northeast
and it's been going that way since 19 i
think it was 37.
uh so there's quite a history we started
the northeast and it expanded
became a national organization uh
grew into four regions um
it i i think it's one of the
the the better regions is here in the
northeast
if i can i interrupt can i do that
thanks i have to interrupt him all the
time anyway
um council state governments is a
membership organization
uh the state legislatures themselves
are the members so the fact that new
hampshire
and all of the 11 states pays dues
to council of state governments means
that you
all individually are members
of csg erc and can take advantage of
what we have to offer
and what we have to offer is
we do policy summits
we do conferences we do webinars
we write blogs but we also do research
for you
if you have a question or a problem
it with some of your legislation that
your
able committee researcher or assistant
can't handle
call us up and we will ask what other
states are doing in our region
on issues that are of importance to you
um when we were
chairs we were appointed to council
state governments
and we got so involved with the
organization
which we encourage you to do as well and
through
csg we got to meet legislators
from vermont maine massachusetts
connecticut
and they became our friends so that we
could call them up
and say hey carolyn partridge over in
vermont
what's going on with pet issues over
there
and we would have a nice long discussion
about how they're dealing with issues
any legislation that they've come up
with that help
um and having that wider
view of what's going on rather than
insular new hampshire alone
really does help in developing good
legislation
and networking is is is great
but yeah i uh let me just tag on to that
uh so often we would hear of a
problem somewhere uh in new hampshire
that we had to deal with
and you know you sit there think you
know i remember kevin ryan
in connecticut talking about that and
you call kevin up
and he may have the answer for you
uh or or at least something will send
you off in the right direction
uh so the the networking is
just second to none uh i
really encourage people to to get
involved
and and do that networking uh it's worth
it just for that
uh the other thing i might go into is
uh tara and i put on programs
now our expertise is agriculture and
rural policy
uh we we put on programs we have
an annual summer meeting it's always
been in person
it rotates between states and provinces
uh and in fact we've even been deployed
we put on usually two different programs
maybe
three at one of those annual meetings
uh but every other committee meets we
csg is not just agriculture and rural
uh it's i'm gonna miss something but
it's environment
it's fiscal uh it's nuclear waste
uh it's transportation uh
education uh so there are several
different committees in fact i think
there are nine of them
uh of which agricultural rural is is one
uh tara and i have also put on some
special
uh policy summits uh over the last
couple of years
uh we've we did one in wilmington
delaware
uh what else we do dara we did
wilmington delaware
on um rural broadband and we did
providence rhode island
on agri-tourism um we've done
policy summits and conferences on hemp
on the financial effects of covid19
on agriculture and agriculture economy
um yeah we we've done
a lot of things and the one thing about
csg is that we
rely on you as our members to tell us
what policy issues interest you
and then we will put on webinars or
conferences and get
speakers and experts to actually talk to
you and answer questions
about anything that might be of interest
to you
whether it's on a bill that you're
dealing with or just some
area that you think new hampshire should
be heading in as far as agriculture and
um we have usually
somewhere between 20 and 30 people show
up to
any of our meetings or programs
uh and they pretty much run from puerto
rico up to
ontario um so
there's a good good cross-section of
people
uh one of the things we do at our annual
meeting
always on our very first meeting
is we go around the room state by state
and let each state talk about what they
are with what their big issues are in
their state and
what kinds of things they're working on
and
uh that really is
probably the the best thing we've ever
done
we just do it every time and people love
it
uh at least the representatives because
they hear what's going on elsewhere
uh and you know it's the kickoff to
networking with
with your peers in other states
let's see we offer research as well if
you
have a particular question that you
can't
really get an answer to that really
involves what other states are doing
um or if they've had any experience with
a certain problem or
issue call us up and we'll contact all
the other states we'll do
research into their existing laws and
um policies that they have so that we
can get back to you
we're just another research arm for you
to call on
and it's all free so don't think that
you're going to get charged for it
or anything like that and we're sitting
here at home
just just give us a call yeah
and and to add on to that uh
about a year ago we got a call from new
jersey
and it was from legislative staff
asking if we've ever seen any issues
with a fire marshal
uh and we did a lot of research and we
couldn't find
you know doing the right thing in this
case i guess
uh he went after
the blueberry farms in new jersey and if
you know much about
new jersey that's probably their biggest
uh agriculture industry is blueberries
and uh he he went after them for
workforce housing and insisted they had
to have
uh sprinkler systems in their workforce
housing
and it was going to put some of those
blueberry farms
out of existence uh so
we we did research across the country to
see if
any other state was requiring that
so we gave our research back to them and
we haven't heard anything about it since
but
but on a subject that's related to that
i remember
that new hampshire had a
requirement um in their fire marshal
division
that state farms
and fairs i'm sorry bears had to have
sprinkler systems in their barns
um installing those are sometimes forty
thousand fifty thousand dollars
per building and these buildings are
used
maybe two weeks out of the year and so
that would have put a lot of our little
local
um town fairs county fairs
and state fairs out of business i think
that they're still requiring that i
don't know how they got around it but
it's
it's issues like that that you can call
us
up for and we will be happy to do
uh we again we have
an annual meeting that's usually in
either july or
august and again it's
normally in different states
it just kind of goes around it was
supposed to have been
in new hampshire uh
past summer uh but because of covid
it got cancelled and it became a virtual
one
and it the next one was supposed to be
in
ontario and it looks like that's been
uh cancelled as the wrong word going to
be virtual
uh but new hampshire is going to be
up for the year 2022 it's going to be
held in manchester by then hopefully
we're all going to be meeting in person
and we can have conferences again
fingers crossed
and so we encourage you all to take
advantage of going down to manchester
and sitting in on all of the seminars
and and
uh the the organization is also
our the chair for our our chairs for our
committee our co-chairs
uh it's senator judy schwenk from
pennsylvania and carroll and partridge
a legislative representative from
vermont
that all of the committees are led by
legislators as chairs we try to get one
senator and one representative we try to
get one from each party
uh and uh it's
actually we're we've been pretty
successful in getting one from each
party and
including one senator one rep
but also the entire eastern region
is led by legislators
and the alcoholic ones the ones that
left in december
again we're from new hampshire um
why did i just go blank uh lucy webber
from the house and sharon carson from
the senate
yes they were our chairs
and our national chair was senator lou
d'alessandro
from manchester united so we have a big
new hampshire presence in the kansas
state government
one thing that i think that we um stress
is that we as a region in new england
are 11 northeastern states individually
in washington don't have much of a voice
i mean we're small little states we
don't have a lot of clout
but as a region when you group us all
together 11 states speaking with one
voice
which we do because we vote on issues
and vote on resolutions
um that we want to see past
we submit that to washington and people
look
they say oh new york state pennsylvania
massachusetts connecticut
are all in favor of this so let's take a
listen
so um that is one thing that makes the
eastern region of csg so valuable
is that we have more clout because we
speak as
a group um whereas we wouldn't
individually
another thing that we're doing is and i
see this happening more and more
is the latest thing is interstate
compact
cross border working together
um as a region and
we are looking into doing a number of
um compacts up here in the northeast
so that should be interesting one of
them is going to be on
state need inspection programs being
able to cross
different lines um another is
teacher certification and education
it's issues like this that we can maybe
work as a region
so that it's not all just little pods
working against each other
one thing one issue that we're going to
be dealing with we're going to have a
webinar on this in february
is the potential to set up regional
food systems as you remember
in march and april when cobit first came
out
the agricultural marketing and food
delivery
was horribly um
destroyed so we in order to prevent that
from happening again
um regions are getting together states
are getting together to
look to see how we can
small in make smaller and more localize
our food production and food
transportation
delivery in potential
crisis times or emergency
situations we don't want to starve up
here just because we can't get food
in from california so that's one thing
that we're going to be looking in
we'll send you all links to that
these webinars that we're holding anyone
can join in there's no cost
so watch for emails from us
with links and invitations so we hope
uh one of the things we're going to talk
about this summer
at our summer program again will be
uh rural broadband
we've had several different sessions on
broadband but it continues to be a hot
topic
especially because of covet uh with
all the kids at home and you know
what happens when they don't have
broadband that they can use
to get into the schools uh in fact my
my grandson is one of them um
so uh we're going to cover that again
this summer
uh i i'll also go back to uh
the interstate compacts just for one
second
one of the things we talked about one
time and and
really never finished following up on
but um we have farmers that live
in corners of states or on state
boundaries
that may have land uh that they are
farming
in two different states uh in fact i
believe we
we i know we had one in cheshire county
that had land in three different states
new hampshire
vermont and massachusetts
and uh they have to go
and get a pesticide permit from all
three states
uh and pay for it uh
you know they've got to keep up the
credits on it uh
why can't we have an interstate compact
that says
you know if you've got a pesticide
permit in one state
it it'll be good in all three states if
you have landed in all three
yep does anybody have any questions
about council state governments or
anything that we do
or what we can do for you or anything
yeah well um i just wanted to this isn't
so much as a question it's a comment i
just want to thank you for
helping me find the right contact at the
usda for
discussing hemp stuff with so
i think i just to amplify you know what
you can do for us
another thing is figuring out the right
person to talk to about a particular
issue
exactly that's what we do and that's
what we like doing
speaking of washington we have an
associate of ours
who is a csg consultant as well
who his name is fran boyd and he is in
washington
he's been in washington for years and
years he
is an agricultural specialist so he
knows
everything that's going on in the house
and senate act committees
he knows what the politics are there
what the farm bill is doing
so like having that piece of information
is so important because what we do in
new hampshire
as far as agriculture is concerned
depends a lot on what comes to the state
from washington so knowing that in
advance
the rules and regulations and the timing
of things coming in
makes a big difference so yeah and and
friend
always presents at our at the minimum
at iran it tells us what's going on in
washington that will
so it's a great organization we hope
that you take advantage of it
um and again congratulations you guys
you're going to have a great time
well listen we thank you both for coming
in
csg is is definitely an excellent uh
excellent resource for us as a
environment and ag committee and
we appreciate you guys always being
there and we know we get extra special
service since you two both were chairs
of this committee
you got it about new hampshire and
howard i took the liberty
of asking sherm packard
to appoint uh you
representative aaron and uh
representative bixby to our committee
thank you i appreciate your confidence
in the three of us
and uh if if so appointed i'm sure we
will do our best to
represent our committee well in our
state and
and anyone else on the committee that
would like to go to the meetings and
join in
they're always welcome exactly it's fun
it really is excellent
well thank you both very much we
appreciate uh all that you do for us
we appreciate you coming in and talking
to us i'm sure
we'll be in touch yeah go ahead i have
this let me um
share the screen if i can hold on a sec
i wanted to show you our contact
information
um so that there you go
there are telephone numbers and um
email addresses if you want to get in
touch with us
leave that up for just a minute so
everyone can have a chance to
catch it the other thing you do why
don't you uh could you send us an email
without that same info
i have everybody's email address whether
they want me to or not
so i'm going to be sending you the
information that we have here
very good okay well thank you again for
the
excellent presentation and uh we look
forward to seeing you throughout the
session
hopefully in person as you said well but
i just saw just one last note i took a
look
at your some of the bills that are
coming to your committee yeah
do you know that you're going to be um
voting on the state spider
i did i saw that all right good luck on
that one
maybe
if not we're going to send one to
you got to know what you're voting on
right
arachnophobia right right all right well
thank you again appreciate it
very much thank you all right everybody
we're
getting pretty close to the end here i
did receive an email while we were
actually on this call from uh aaron
goulet the chief of staff and it
looks like we will be cleared to start
uh
hybrid meetings beginning the week of
the 25th again i don't know which day
we're going to have yet that will be
determined
so i would say keep an eye out over the
next few days for
something from me and in the calendar as
uh
as we start to move forward and schedule
some hearings so
that will be coming up uh
that pretty much completes my uh my
presentation and
oh we have a hand up from uh rep maria
perez
yeah i wanna i wanna say that uh i'm so
happy to be part of these um
group and then um i'm excited it was a
lot of information
to kick in but i'm excited because
um i i feel that uh
they had positive energy like every
everything is so positive
and then um i'm i'm excited they work
together and um
yeah i'm happy to be part of be with you
guys and then i hopefully
someday we can be in person and then we
can all meet and talk about
our families and everything everything
all good
yeah well thank you i appreciate it
uh could you possibly send me if you
notice the contact list that i sent out
i don't have an email or a phone number
for you so
uh perez so whatever you're willing to
share if you could email it to me and i
will update the contact list
i've had one or two changes too from the
contact list that i did send out so look
for an updated one
rep highland i don't have a phone number
for you and if you'd like
to have one listed on there feel free to
send that along to me as well
and i will thank you and i will get the
list updated and
send it out any other questions concerns
thoughts comments step up now's your
chance
well the only other thing i would say
and it's kind of not related to the
committee is that
if any of you besides um representative
murray needs help in getting name badges
i can forward you the same email that i
sent to her
and you can get that squared away
thank you judy appreciate it
well everyone i think this was a good
fun
kickoff and uh appears we got through
all of the
technological issues in the beginning
and hopefully we can get smoother as we
go along
so uh we'll not have to
deal with any of those any further
all right i don't see any i will be in
touch as i said with
updates as we go forward and if you have
anything that
jumps up and you want to talk about feel
free to call me
email me whatever your preferred method
of communication is and we'll uh
we'll have a conversation you all have a
great rest of your day and uh
thank you for coming on the environment
ag committee i look forward to meeting